a lot of focus in recent days has been
on actions in the donbash region and in
the declaration by the kremlin that it
recognizes the independence of the
russian-backed separatist groups in this
eastern region of ukraine
but the fact is that by land and sea and
air russia's got forces effectively
surrounding ukraine on three sides
and in neighboring belarus widely
considered a russian satellite state we
can map the arrival of military
equipment take this airfield in massa
southern belarus it's less than 50 miles
from the border
two weeks ago it was empty the runway
has not even been cleared here it is now
there are the piano keys at the end of
the runway pilots need those when
they're making their approach so they
can see what they're doing when they
land and here's a close-up of the
vehicles at the airfield now there's no
indication yet that they're moving into
their combat formations but we will see
and on the east ukrainian border there's
plenty of sightings of russian military
vehicles just a few miles from the
border as in this video
and you'll see here that these vehicles
they have some very specific markings it
looks like a sort of mixed bag you would
expect to find with mechanized infantry
now lots of these vehicles
have led western specialists to scratch
their heads a bit about what the precise
meaning of these markings really are and
there's lots of different variations
these markings are there normally so
that units can recognize each other in
the fog of war and remember ukraine
operates a lot of russian equipment so
there might be quite a lot of fog of war
but it almost always indicates that
these vehicles are anticipating going
into combat and they normally only
appear just before they expect to be
deployed
but the image that's made the biggest
impression on me as a military analyst
is this satellite image of a field
hospital on the outskirts of belgium
that's only 25 miles in ukraine's border
when military organizations bring their
field hospitals and blood supplies
forward
it's normally because they expect to do
some fighting
you know western military planners tend
to say that you need more forces than
this for a quick and successful invasion
many military analysts are saying that
if western forces were planning to
invade ukraine they'd want more than
this to do it
so either mr putin is doing this to
frighten everyone
or he believes that the ukrainians will
not fight or be effective if they do and
that he may be able to achieve his quick
and successful invasion even with this
number
well one way or another we'll probably
find out fairly soon